andré bergeron le savez en général de
force ouvrière s'est mis dans la
position du malade qui lui se trouve un
petit peu l'écart de ces négociations en
main des raisons que l'on sait très
attaché à tous les problèmes qui
touchent d'une manière générale la
protection sociale nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que le dicta de la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français et des conséquences sur le
remboursement des assurés sociaux
il faut admettre dans cette histoire que
l'on forme aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de
médecins qu'il en faudra alors
naturellement cela des conséquences mais
enfin si les médecins continuent à se
conduire de cette manière ils finiront
par mettre en cause le caractère libéral
de la médecine